Back to the Future fans were in tears  this weekend as Michael J fox and  Christopher Lloyd shared a really  emotional reunion at New York Comic-Con  yeah the pair who starred as teenager  Marty McFly and The Eccentric scientist  doc Emmett Brown in the 1985 classic  stepped out together on Saturday during  a panel to speak about the films like  yes and Not only was The Reunion really  emotional for fans but also for  Christopher who took to Instagram  shortly after to praise Michael and the  film's dedicated fan base writing this I  cherish these moments thank you to New  York Comic-Con and my dear friend  Michael J fox and most importantly all  you wonderful fans who showed up this  year or showed up year after year this  is all because of you this is heavy and  in a new clip taken by a fan which has  been viewed nearly 10 million times on  Twitter the Dynamics Duo shared an  emotional Embrace on stage take a look  [Applause]  thank you  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]